toda la mitad sur de España Tiene
activado algún tipo de alerta por la
primera ola de calor del verano que tras
su comienzo el sábado hoy lunes alcanza
el pico de temperaturas tras una noche
con termómetros que marcaban hasta 25
grados en zonas de Andalucía al sur del
país las horas del día traen consigo
hasta 44 grados o más en ciertas zonas
de esas regiones española como Sevilla o
Córdoba que han activado el aviso rojo
por riesgo extremo ahí hoy se inicia con
la reducción de jornadas de trabajo en
ciertos sectores como la construcción o
la agricultura donde se activa la
jornada intensiva de siete horas que
iniciaría entre las seis y las 7 de la
mañana para así evitar las horas de más
calor aquí en Madrid donde está activada
la alerta naranja se rozarán los 39
grados esta tendencia a las horas de
calor en los primeros meses del verano
va en aumento y los expertos en
metrología aseguran que el cambio
climático está detrás de esta crecida
según datos de la agencia Estatal de
meteorología el número de días bajo ola
de calor en junio en los últimos 12 años
multiplica por cuatro al de años
anteriores ya 2022 fue el más cálido en
España desde que hay registros es decir
en 1961 y esta Primavera de 2023 fue la
más calurosa y la segunda más seca de
esa Desde esa misma fecha las
temperaturas de este primer episodio de
calor extremo del verano español
empezarán a bajar a partir del jueves
cuando los valores volverán a ser más
típicos de esta época del año Pese a que
el norte de la Península no está
sufriendo estas altas temperaturas ni
este calor sofocante sí podrá ver una
significativa empeoramiento de la
calidad del aire puesto que parte del
humo de los incendios de Canadá estará
llegando al noroeste de la península
ibérica